Oh
go
[Music]
welcome to the gameplay demo walkthrough
up CD Projekt RED upcoming title
cyberpunk 2077 a narrative driven
open-world RPG set in a dark version of
the future before we start a small but
important disclaimer the gameplay you're
about to see is from a work in progress
version of the game everything you see
is potentially subject to change in
cyberpunk 2077 you can fully customize
your character using a deep
customization system for this demo we're
going to play a female keep in mind that
what you see here is not final we just
want to give you a glimpse of what will
be possible in the released game this is
an RPG so before we get into our
appearance we need to define our
backstory what you choose here will
unlock different possibilities later in
the game also you can use an array of
different options to modify how you look
these include body type hair style
tattoos makeup skin tone and many many
more
but visuals aren't everything you'll
also be able to customize your initial
attribute setup you'll notice we didn't
pick a class cyberpunk 2077 features a
fluid class system and you'll be able to
modify your class throughout the game
this demo takes place near the beginning
of the game v and her friend Jackie
along with a net runner named teba are
hired to find and retrieve
missing person a girl whose locator
implant went done that's clear go
Wow on your right cyberpunk 2077 is a
first-person role-playing game this
perspective enables us to maximize your
immersion should have full access to
point eight seconds your turn what I
live the way I know
[Music]
is that her that our target v-rooms too
simple
not our girl I think just looking it
looks like these scavengers are
kidnapping people to harvest their
implants
[Music]
okay things are about to get heated
[Applause]
we'll take a reflex booster that
temporarily allows us to use the perez
nick offerman
this is Korres Nicole
[Music]
he's bought that
can't be [__]
got none - [__] it you
look out on the balcony got a window on
the left go
anymore
[__] layout shows only one room left
the bathroom go
sure hope our target in their copper oh
nice
thank you gotta got our target we make
it she live this does not look good no
in a minute checking into biome on
[Music]
Sandra Dorset NC 5704 42 got a winner
well she will be if we can get her to a
hospital
she's trauma team Platinum to platinum
[__] DD should have food in if she
sneezed something's jamming the biome on
signal talk to me t bug virus probably
locate her neuro socket should be a
shard slotted inch it's probably on that
if we clear it free up the signal TT
could actually drop in take her off our
hands
[Music]
got the shark removing it now done an
emergency evacuation unit has been
dispatched and is due to arrive at your
location in Beaumont claims Rommel beer
in three minutes
like the [__] cavalry let's get her
out of here your premium plan will cover
90% of the projected costs of your nests
[Music]
yeah that she's flatlining do you need
to know what's going on Jeffy err hypo
China she's stable yeah
well get her outside I'll cover you it
turns out a virus disrupted the girls
locator implant we fixed that and now
help is inbounds
get her up Terrace
[Music]
click the patient on the stretcher
five steps back now I said step back
Dixie 133 to control patient MC five
seven zero four four two secured
stimulants being administered 70
milligrams dopamine 110
[Music]
hey give us a lift out of here
got in connection t bug out all clear
that was trauma to blow a kind of
high-end premium medical insurance must
time for what book said we've delivered
the target and Tebow has notified us
that the scavengers have called in
reinforcements let's get out of here
before they arrive I got that Eddie's
for new wheels now I had something real
fine to about Joanna
probably blowing out on booze in three
days talking about somebody else jack
he's no more than a Content combat
cyberpunk is a mature visceral
experience and as such it will let you
explore a variety of different
interactions with the game world and as
you just saw its people the job was a
success and V obviously has some money
to burn big is my boss and I've been a
hot date with my Ripper duck the doc we
also pass on your cool on get down here
subway entrance with your iron okay
Jackie has just told us to get some big
news for us and we have an appointment
with our River today before we leave
let's take a good look around our party
good morning night city the song on the
radio is by rocker boy Johnny silver
it's part of our creative process to
draw inspiration from the pen and paper
system created by Mike Pond Smith and to
put our own 2077 spin on
[Music]
let's go grab our keys
okay
we'll take these trusty pistol
and also grab our jacket since cyberpunk
2077 is an RPG the jacket not only
provides us with protective stats like
arm but it also increases our streak
street cred is a form of experience the
player acquires by completing side
missions it is used to unlock new
vendors and content throughout night
scene alright let's go meet Jack V's
current apartment is located inside a
mega build a huge building complex that
forms a micro society of its own in this
timeline and technology in the world
have evolved in some ways that seem
familiar when but entirely surprising in
others as an example in this world
people pay with Edmonds slang for euro
dollars we make sure to route every
detail in the world's law so everything
has its purpose and slaves believable
a big part of our RPG experience is
having a world that is interactive here
a generic ad has morphed into an
advertisement specifically tailored to
the moment of informing her of the
nearest venues she can purchase the
problem in this case it shows us where
to find some nicola soda
five gonna see that even more than me
electric time
this is Wilson one of night city's many
guns we won't be checking his wares but
you can purchase and upgrade your
weapons and gear throughout the city
cyberpunk 2077 is set in night City a
bustling metropolis located on the coast
of the free state of north California
it's a dystopian similar violence and
oppression are the norm we are working
hard to make Knight City fully realized
seamless open world with no loading
screens currently we're in watson a
former industrial this world where a
crime now mixes with money three times
three times yo the piece of [__] now
give it back my edit
debut out man
give me some truth to that
we've greatly enhanced our crowd and
community systems to create the most
believable city in any open-world games
to date the city streets are bustling
with crowds of people from all facets of
life while living their lives within a
full day and night sight
[Music]
okay there's Jack and finally she's
happening
what's up jack Dexter DeSean yeah
sound familiar there was to talk to you
okay you see that caddy need to walk on
over there and get us a job ina
I'll meet him talk
via zero rippers it turns out we've
caught the attention of one of Knights
city's biggest players Dexter DeSean a
fixer a person who gets things done he
wants to meet up and discuss a job you
do let's see what he has for us
yo miss V a pleasure
Liz rolled
scanning the serious job just now
playing gargantuan compared us smashing
up a scaffold you interested
interested sure tell me more
glad to hear before we can start in on
this though I need to be sure sure you
all right
all right in the nature of this test
starting the show
Seve got a classic tale for you psycho
gang just doing his thing jump the core
convoy got away
now I need me that little combat bar
they call it the flathead of course I
got the Eddie's to buy it but me and the
Maelstrom boys ain't the best of friends
no flow to our convo see
who's the woman corporal agent she's on
the hunt for the dogs who sold the gang
blooms info on the convoy got herself a
prisoner their chief suspect looks like
they're going on 20 hours since the
convoy was jumped and she still don't
have me a guilty party gotta be
desperate by now be wise to think how
you could use it got any questions for
me
we're on at all I think time I got to
work beautiful here's hoping my inkling
checks out
so see you at the afterlife soon as the
job's done do good and this will be the
start of a beautiful friendship based on
heaps of Eddie's
it seems dexter has given us a test of
sorts to see if we're a word he wants us
to retrieve a piece of hi-tech combat
gear a local gang stole from the
military medical will be able to
approach this job from a variety of
angles let's try calling the military
to see where that leads hi
heard you were looking for some tech
let's talk first exit off skyline going
towards the NID storm channel under the
overpass meet you there the situation's
tricky because the contract Giver as a
corporate agent who seems a little
high-strung before we get down to
business it's a great idea to visit our
Ripper though
yeah yeah you see this camp I'll get got
a real whack tape change your [__]
life
crime is a common occurrence night city
is not a safe place life here is not
easy
your heart chakra looks a little out of
whack babe me I can release gonna play
out with Dex it's all here
alright I'll check it out while I wait
for you leave doctor vector will see you
now we're at a ripper doc clinic Ripper
Doc's are specialist vendors who offer
people the possibility to install or
upgrade their cyber need to bump up my
specs and get a grip really no finally
Vic [__] just got real hit in the major
leagues
got a job from Dexter Shawn the Dexter
does shot something but let me guess has
been paid yet
quick Ryan Vic I'll bring you the Eddy's
later with interest you know I will
last time I swear now sit
that's Karoshi best I've got
and she'd be about right under the
circumstances now Jackie an you perusing
shoes while I scan see what's going on
inside we're going to install both an
optical scanner mark one like I said
decent enough scanner just plays data on
your cornea and a subdermal weapon grip
links not labeled and to be perfectly
honest not entirely sure where the hell
I got it still looks like it'll talk to
Karoshi tech oh I'm ready carve away
okay okay now for the fun stuff they
made you League on with yours right here
just like that thanks now a bit of an
aesthetic and I can start reading
feel anything duck way by play makes you
sound like a dentist
they're always going on and on don't be
me now remember I'm old I got a shaky
ganic hand could slip lights out for a
minute all right yeah so let's test it
linking you in you might feel a little
discomfort maybe blurred vision low
contrast glitches
so as it look to you with the scanner we
can zoom in on things and take a closer
look this is fantastic beautiful time
for the scanner
additionally we can analyze objects get
details on enemy weak points or gang
affiliation processes read your
intentions work like a charm now draw
your weapon you should see your ammo
count and a brand new sight the
subdermal weapon grip links to our scan
and shows us weapon information like
ammo count and Firelands it also
increases the base damage on all
connected weapons not bad I don't know
what to say say you'll take this and
remember the dosage two whips now and
another two in an hour
thanks again may the best Vic
you're like kids showing what you can do
and once you hit the big time don't
forget where you came from
while some Ripper Doc's operate legally
others provide black-market services for
the right price they can even offer to
install illegal military-grade cyber
we're left a few minutes ago said he'd
wait outside
well Roshi
well figs got a soft spot for you Hina
come on how about you use them fancy as
optics to scan my new wheels sure but
you'll have to let him take it first bin
hey just watch the big jump
[Music]
a problem
this guy looks an awful lot like one of
those scavengers we took out earlier so
that tells me that wasn't no coincidence
Jackie's car is a super-powered sports
car running on to to the super fuel of
the future players can explore night
city freedom in many different cars on
bikes and in other types of fields
this does not look good it looks like
the scavengers earlier still angry
all right
I think we got rid of that was intense
night city never sleeps danger lurks
around every corner even in daytime
random encounters like these are an
example of how your actions directly
influence your open world experience
let's get the [__] out of here
okay Jackie
they're done riding our asses scoffs
maybe should be looking for a new spot
to slice and dice not coming after us
who knows real messed up in their horse
cars saw it yourself
many forces are fighting for control of
night city but the mega corporations are
the real show room the agent we're going
to meet represents mill attack one of
the largest companies in the private
military sector while we stop it
[Music]
remember the corpo off deficit chard
ringer she's in the area and we're gonna
meet let me guess she's in hot water
desperate when you think you can use
that see if I can yeah
since cyberpunk 2077 is an RPG
preparation will be key when dealing
with knight city's powerful especially
when these are core bones instead of
just rushing in let's assess the
situation with our freshly installed
Karoshi optical scanner there let's take
a closer look
composite armor cars a [__] tank yeah
Milotic about it
yeah gotta do this don't you move a damn
muscle not unless I start that is
these guys are levels higher than we are
let's try to approach them carefully
stout take it you were the one to call
yep we wanted you're smart calm the hell
down what is it
you're insane I'll know in two seconds
flat that [__] thing ready all set
are you here alone the core Bo's have
hacked us through our personal link and
have subjected us to a kind of lie
detector program the dialog system in
cyberpunk 2077 is fully gameplay driven
I asked if you came alone yep
just little old me she's lying search
the area
it's a piece of [__] Anthony Gilchrist
did he or another [__] at millet
eques info to you or anyone else about a
convoy it might be tempting to reach for
the gun but the consequence is kind I
remember these guys are really - [__]
checks out you got nothing on me nothing
won't get away with this you [__]
you're dead
somebody shut him up take me home now
all right I have no idea who you're
working for or what you even want but
you better give me something solid or I
will end you
I've got an offer oh you are stretching
this better be [__] good gang goons
who ripped you off I know where to find
him they got a bot I want give me the
funds to buy that but you can do it you
want with the gang I don't give a [__]
about the thieves
I want my mold friendship 50k just
enough to buy you your bot thing is
chips got to make it into the thieves
terminal that's all I need
think you can do that then we got a deal
fine I'm in
try to [__] me in anyway and I'll be
seeing you real soon you're making a
mistake
this cuts good is dead the agent gave us
the money to buy the bot we need from
the game by choosing to call the
militant early we have now opened up a
non-violent path through this quest of
course we could try and keep the money
but that would mean we'd have to take
the merchandise by force which requires
a lot of firepower no signal so I stay
put
good thing too went down about like I
expected made a deal and we're good to
meet with Maelstrom now
be there soon what do you expect courts
don't forgive will forget even these
board [__] since that feel the pressure
that's why they'll hold up in the
[__]
praying to the Almighty trip six gotta
move the tech but they can't cuz your
new best friend from the trip down
tanked out SUV he's just begging them to
try how you want to do this even now we
can choose how to approach this quest do
we go in guns blazing or do we try to
negotiate for the plan simple we pay
with the corpus cred and get up you're
calling this for this demo let's try the
more diplomatic approach top [__] all we
needs for them to buy it
don't know you wanna talk to Royce main
roof I'm waiting
little devil prepared all strapping
militant gear sico butch chromed out
with military-grade hardware worth
millions
the guys were about to meet are
dangerous they are members of the
maelstrom and their obsession with body
modification goes way beyond even this
world standards on their path to
becoming machine
they don't shy away from even the most
extreme measures anti-personnel mine
shrapnel spitter my favorite gang goons
getting creative with their gear it
looks like they made this abandon all
foods meat factory their hideout
charming another one seriously
maybe we should have taken him by
surprise
little late for regrets like that got us
in their sights now just keep moving
they cool you're just trying to spook us
remember we've chosen to buy the tech
not stealing hopefully this will get
fast and cheap this is a pretty well
guarded place you can imagine what would
have happened if we'd taken the violent
path
what
looking to buy a bought model MTO d12
looks like a spider couch planting
you don't occur peak around the court
see if we got anything like that
well [__] sit down
I'll stand can't move on your culo makes
you an easy target
sit down that really necessary hombre I
ain't your hombre
sit
sit your ass down for I played a bullet
you Skype sit down
this ain't gonna end well all right [__]
it
Bravo
come on lighten up
ever with
better
[Music]
now we can talk
- bye
suit yourself
[__] tricked-out state of the artist
don't even got no standard port
bells whistles though dynamic camel
water and motor impulses rather than
that of the human nervous system its
actuators are actually pinpoint titanium
fiber and it can go anywhere literally
watch it fully integrated blink tubes
what the spider starts climbing up walls
dangling from the ceilings
you could lose your lunch so what'd you
think me up and let's get the [__] out
of here the buck I'll take
two questions what the [__] going on
and who the [__] is this
[Music]
got 50 large and Scratchy
and you positively reek of militant
Dexter do chanson
Dexter Dashon threats go plate saddle
[__] not him
we'll pay for the bottom get away how
much you say you had 50k Fred's on this
move it
not the smoothest deals but it worked
out the end right flight that's a good
Giri
it'll do the trick whatever that trick
is [__]
it turns out the cred ship we got from
the military agency tained a virus are
fried there's sis their leader is making
a break for the tech in this way before
we figure out a way to leave let's grab
the splinter that controls the bottom
from one of these dead males from the
inspection system allows us to take a
closer look at the splinter you can
inspect specific items to reveal details
that can help in solving quests okay
let's equip this plate to our chip wares
which is done the body will now follow
us wherever we go all right what else do
we have here nice a street modified Tech
shotgun tech weapons fire rounds that
penetrate walls and other type stuff
they also have an alternate fire mode
that allows you to power up shots and
deal more damage
it looks like there are several ways out
of this room like those gates for
example however you'd have to be a
skilled net runner to hack into this
term
luckily our engineering skills should
allow us to disassemble that maintenance
panel so we can get through the door
there are many skills in the game that
players can apply in solving problems
the engineering skill can be used to fix
disassemble and is arm devices block
actually passes through here so at this
point we're going to unlock the
abilities of a high-end character to
showcase some of the different mechanics
we have in the
one of the new weapon modules we now
have installed is a ricochet targeting
system connected to our eyes this allows
players to bounce bullets off walls and
hit enemies hiding behind cover
this is another targeting system that
will reveal enemies behind walls paired
with the penetrating rounds of our tech
shot it's a deadly combination
looks like we found some loot this is a
smart gun it's one of the more advanced
weapons in the game allowing the bullets
to track and follow their target it's
one of many different weapons players
can acquire weapons are built of modules
that allow for deep customization and
progression this way you can be sure to
find something that will suit your place
the toughest bastards guarding this
route
just to remind everything you've seen
and are about to see including this
particular feature about to show e is
from a work-in-progress version of the
game and may change over the course of
development okay let's try something
different
Tommy we're going to take this guy down
and connect directly to his neural sign
in the world of cyber once you are
jacked into a network you have access to
everything it connects to through this
Maelstrom gangman we've now connected to
the gang hideouts internal network this
is the building's personnel system let's
focus on the squad containing the
Maelstrom gang or are we just connected
from here we can deploy software that
affects the whole squad for now we'll
simply unlock the ability to perform
quick hacks all right time to show off
our new high-level abilities with quick
end using the backdoor we unlock the
minute ago we'll install a virus that
jams the connection between the
Maelstrom ganger and his weapon this
will prevent him from firing nice some
of you might recognize these mantis
blades we can also double jump and
bounce off of walls which makes us a
very agile fast solo
I'll check down here
sweet we just found a corporate tackle
for / weapons our top of the line let's
scan this guy and see what's going on
it looks like Royce is back and his prey
he's got an armored exoskeleton you
won't be able to get rid of him that
easily
our weapons are not dealing a lot of
damage because he's packing in an
autonomous train
luckily the scan we performed earlier
reveal the week's attacking should bring
the shield deck
[Music]
shields down let's finish him up
okay let's put him down and get this job
over
that wasn't the smoothest raid but we've
got the bots and Dex should be happy but
think back what would have happened if
we hadn't met with the militant or told
Royce about the agent and her plans or
just decided to buy the bought ourselves
so many options so many possibilities
and each will have consequences that
will ripple through the game world and
your story and that's just one quest
let's head out and finish the job
[__] god damn time let's get out of here
[Music]
you know we really ought to work
together more often your chip had the
clap
that's not discrete you set me up I
[__] you over you [__] the gang over
somewhere at the start of the story
somebody [__] the Corp see how this
works now only the Corp gets what it
wants remember that
[Music]
being a raging [__] to whoever's doing
my dirty work for me
okay let's call Jackson tell him how
things went down Bubba no sir
hey mr. Dex get us that table at the
afterlife just my gut now you know well
you were right to
[Music]
[__] I believe it I know major leagues
we're in a cop means ride the door open
but the only thing I want to pry open
right now is a bottle of scotch oh no
not another three nighter what Papa
water need to get to know this city jack
not just gun in hand I want to say Amen
I now we finished the job but our story
is just beginning this concludes our
gameplay demo watch thanks for
[Music]
you